[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver pour cette édition spéciale
consacrée à cette année particulière
qu'on a tous vécu ce 16 mars c'était il
ya un an jour pour jour le début du
confinement en france les français vont
être confiné à domicile comme le sont
déjà les italiens nous sommes en guerre
sanitaire dit emmanuel macron dans une
allocution télévisée
mais à cette même date il y a un an que
se passe-t-il dans le reste du monde
comment les pays vont-ils réagir à cette
pandémie
où en est le monde aujourd'hui et
quelles sont les perspectives de retour
à la normale est bien pour le savoir
nous vous proposons ce matin un tour du
monde exceptionnelle grâce au
correspondant du figaro nous irons ainsi
en asie en israël au royaume uni en
italie et aux etats unis
en plateau nous ferons un point sur les
événements en italie grâce à paolo levi
de lagence alezane ça et nous répondrons
à vos questions sur les avancées
sanitaires et scientifiques en france
avec vincent bordenave du service
sciences et médecine du figaro je vous
propose que nous prenions tout de suite
la direction de l'asie le chemin de
l'asie même avec sébastien fait à
l'éthique nous attend bonjour sébastien
falletti aura correspondant du figaro en
asie ces deux chines qu'est partie la
pandémie il y a un an et il y a un an la
wii la ville de bourg ain était au
centre des conversations
ce 16 mars 2020 que se passe-t-il en
chine où en est l'épidémie
eh bien il ya un an exactement la chine
est en train de vaincre le virus mais le
démon du virus comme selon le terme
utilisé par le président jean ping qui
est monté au créneau dans cette lutte
contre la pandémie
le président chinois s'est rendu à
houran le 10 mars
et donc il s'est rendu à un moment où la
ville était toujours sous cloche confiné
coupé du monde
elle est depuis le 23 janvier lorsque le
président prend cette décision
exceptionnelle de couper du monde la
région du roubaix c'est à peu près 150
millions de personnes et à l'époque
c'est une décision j'ai jamais prise
dans l'histoire de l'humanité et qui va
de motiver à faire école comme vous le
savez partout il conclut en europe et
donc au genre il y a un an la chine
après s'est mise en retrait raquette
commence à voir le bout du tunnel
la ville va rester sous cloche encore
une conne avril mais la présence du
président sur place indiquait déjà à
l'époque que les mesures très strict de
licence en sciences sociales
commençaient à porter leurs fruits
et donc c'était la fin de c'était le
début de la fin de deux mois extrêmement
violent en chine on tenait que les
pignes avait commencé dès à partir de
janvier au cours de février on a
vraiment un style mandat paul
d'apocalypse de on a été repeint par les
mêmes tchernobyl à l'époque à pékin
jusqu'à la fin de cette émission on va
vous questionnez de nouveau un peu plus
tard tout à l'heure arnaud de la grange
on est avec vous maintenant directes
depuis londres vous m'entendez
le correspondant du figaro à londres le
16 mars 2020 que se passe-t-il au
royaume uni où en est l'épidémie à cette
date là où je suis a démarré assez
lentement la prise de conscience
au royaume uni on sait très bien que
bruce johnson au début même encore en
février ou même début mars plaisante est
en fait en disant d'ailleurs même moi je
continue à serrer les mains à tout le
monde
enfin il a on parlait aussi beaucoup d'
immunité collective zem après tout
autant laisser la population se
contaminer pour atteindre imiter
collective et puis il ya eu quand même
une prise de conscience qui qui qui est
monté devant les chiffres et le 23 mars
était décidé le 1er confinement est
alors donc avec avec des mesures à ces
cas là c'est assez classique même si
c'est monter progressivement en
puissance
et puis il ya eu ce coup de théâtre en
fête quinze jours plus tard à peine
quand boris johnson a été hospitalisé
donc toucher lui même dans sa chair par
la maladie il s'est retrouvé commente en
soins intensifs il a dit plus tard
qu'ils étaient passées relativement près
de la mort enfin que ça aurait pu
dégénérer
et donc voilà il ya eu si vous voulez à
la fois dans
dans l'expérience nationale et puis dans
l'expérience personnelle du premier
ministre il ya une prise de conscience
progressive qui fait qu' on est passé
d'une certaine désinvolture au début sur
le traitement du virus
on est passé à quelque chose de très
stricte avec un premier compliment
un deuxième a été décrétée fin octobre
jusqu'à la fin d'année il a été relâché
très peu de temps et un nouveau
confinement le 5 janvier qui vient juste
de commencer enfin de déconfinement
vient de commencer le 8 mars
mais maintenant il y a énormément de
prudence de la part des autorités
britanniques certains disent même
d'ailleurs trop de lenteur dans dans la
sortie du confinement si arnaud de la
grange ou aussi on vous retrouve dans
quelques minutes
je me tourne vers vous paolo levi
maintenant cette journaliste à lagence
en deçà qui est la principale
principales agences de presse italiennes
merci d'être avec nous en direct ce
matin personne n'a oublié évidemment les
images de l'italie l'an dernier à la
même époque et c'est ces hôpitaux
submergés par l'afflux de patients
ininterrompue on apprendra quelques
jours après le 16 mars d'ailleurs que le
nombre de morts en italie dépasse celui
enregistré en chine
qu'est ce qui se passe en italie à cette
date du 16 mars 2020 dont boké et et
c'est des journées absolument
apocalyptique où qui sonne aussi une
sorte de sonnette d'alarmé morin le
reste les autres pays européens
moi j'étais en france il n'y avait pas
du tout une prise de conscience sur ça
il faisait bon arrêt on avait presque
envie de faire le parallèle avec le
nuage de tchernobyl on avait
l'impression que que ce virus s'arrête
pouvait s'arrêter à la frontière alors
qu'il n'y a rien de plus fluide et
volatiles qu'un virus en italie au
départ
on a été tous pris de court c'est à dire
que le gouvernement tout le monde ne
savais pas quoi faire et on a été le
gouvernement italien était le premier
gouvernement en europe à prendre une
décision absolument inédite pour une
démocratie une européenne c'est-à-dire
de confiner donc de limiter la la
liberté de circulation de ses
concitoyens une chose c'est le fer en
chine
william lin régime bien établie autre
chose c'est le faire dans une grande
démocratie européenne
c'était totalement inédite et totalement
rétabli ça a commencé par la région de
milan la lombardie et après ça c'est dû
à tout en y reviendra également sur ces
mesures
morgane ans après on est encore oui à
nouveau on reviendra mais on y reviendra
justement sur sur l'état de la situation
actuelle en italie on va voir aussi ce
qui se passe aux etats unis
ce 16 mars 2020 que s'y passe-t-il où en
est l'épidémie
adrien jour me correspondant du figaro à
washington répondait à ces questions il
ya quelques heures à peine en direct
depuis washington on écoute les états
unis donc leur première mesure à la fin
du mois de janvier le président trump a
décrété la suspension d entrer sur le
territoire américain pour les
ressortissants étrangers en provenance
de chine
le 31 janvier mais ensuite les seuls
mais les mesures qui sont prises par le
donald trump le son le 13 mars où ils
décrètent un état d'urgence nationale il
explique que c'est une pandémie et que
et que des mesures seront prises
en revanche il ne décrète pas de
confinement national il n'y en aura pas
pendant toute la durée de la crise
tout le monde prend conscience que c'est
un problème trump y compris c'est ce
qu'il expliquera ensuite au journaliste
américain bob woodward
il sait que l'épidémie est une épidémie
de grande ampleur et qui est un problème
de santé publique gravissime
en revanche ils décident pour des
raisons politiques et aussi pour des
raisons personnelles de ne pas il dira
lé dans ses propres termes ne pas
affoler les gens les médias s'emparent
de cette de cette pandémie et notamment
les adversaires démocrates de donald
trump qui en font une sorte de d'armes
pour la battre puisqu'on est en plus en
plus en pleine campagne électorale
donc très rapidement toutes les
questions sanitaires deviennent
extrêmement politisé en partie à cause
de
le trump est en partie à cause de ses
adversaires démocrates bonjour vincent
bordenave
merci d'être en direct avec nous vous
êtes journaliste au service sciences et
métiers du figaro vous êtes là
aujourd'hui pour pour répondre aux
questions des internautes qui sont
posées en direct pendant la diffusion de
cette émission
une question revient elle est
d'actualité parce qu'on en parle
beaucoup ces derniers jours c'est le
vase le vaccin astrazeneca qui a été
autorisée en france il ya quelques temps
et qui on l'espérait ferait aboutir une
campagne de vaccination à vitesse rapide
et finalement et un coup d'arrêt a été
marqué et porté hier puisque on essaye
de voir s'il ne met pas en danger la
santé des patients
il ya maxime qui nous demandent pourquoi
la france a mis autant de temps à
suspendre le vaccin astrazeneca c'est
vrai que des dpi ont pris cette décision
avant que la france s'y engage
il me semble de très bonnes relations
chez ces cas sont vraiment les marginaux
de précaution qui est de stopper cette
campagne de vaccination sans doute dans
l'objectif de la relancer après et de
rassurer les gens parce que c'est vrai
que le contexte est quand même propice à
une épidémie de fausses nouvelles et de
paniquer donc le but a peut-être été de
de poser le temps pour pouvoir repartir
de manière plus sereine après donc c'est
un choix un choix politique qui a été
fait on attend quand même une une
réponse de l'autorité européenne du
médicament dans les dans les prochains
jours donc au plus tard d'ici jeudi qui
devrait trancher sur sur la reprise ou
non de cette campagne de vaccination à
cette pandémie mondiale les
gouvernements assistés de conseillers
scientifiques vont prendre des mesures
parfois radicales
thierry oberlé je sais pas si vous
m'entendez vous êtes le correspondant du
figaro à jérusalem
comment a réagi
israël à l'époque il y a un an pour
faire pour faire face à la pandémie
16 mars il sera elle sort à peine des
élections législatives et on parle
plutôt politique a d'autant plus le
lendemain benyamin nétanyahou se fait
par affronter les juges dans son procès
pour corruption
mais la crise du coronavirus étouffe
tout elle écrase tout ce jour là aussi
le mossad est en opérations secrètes à
l'étranger pour acheter des kits de test
des respirateurs artificiels et des
millions de masques de protection lui
netanyahu lui il annonce que le shin bet
il est désormais autorisé à traquer les
téléphones portables des personnes en
quarantaine politique elle reste chez z
bref c'est la mobilisation générale et
le continent total ne commence le 19
mars le lendemain on enregistre le
premier mort est donc le cas d'infection
s'est envolé il est passé en quelques
jours de 200 à 700 voilà comment tout
affronter quelles sont les mesures qui
vont être prises donc c'est un
confinement général oui c'est absolument
c'est donc le continent général qui
commence le 19 mars
quelle mesure va prendre la chine comme
endiguer l'épidémie on sait qu'elles ont
été assez radical
les mesures qui ont été prises à
l'époque ont été salués par l' oms comme
des médiums jamais pris dans l'histoire
de l'humanité il faut quand même tenir
de la stupeur que lorsque le régime
chinois a décidé donc le 23 janvier de
mettre sous cloche une région entière
d'abord 50 millions de personnes comme
j'ai dit mais ensuite s'est étendu à
d'autres métropoles notamment côtières
et il peut dans le confinement quelqu'un
ose et rural et d'une violence radicale
puisque dans pendant plusieurs semaines
les habitants de maurane n'avait pas le
redescendre même en bas de leurs
immeubles pour une petite promenade
n'avait pas le droit d'aller faire des
courses pour livrer les gens chez eux
donc c'était vraiment un championnat
extrêmement radical co entreprise avec
en plus un contrôle social tac à
l'époque en bas de chez moi à pékin il y
avait un contrôle de température à
l'entrée de mon immeuble
tous les matins et si vous n'aviez plus
de 37 3 on vous envoyer à l'hôpital
donc c'était vraiment un cadre avec un
quadrillage de tout le pays
comme le régime sait le faire avec ces
comités de quartier qui surveillaient la
population partout on a coupé les
transports bien sûr et donc pendant
plusieurs semaines presque deux mois la
chine était vraiment à l'arrêt et les
grandes villes avaient des à part de
ville fantôme complète alors toutes ces
choses là l époque nous paraissait
incroyable mais il était dit difficile
même d'imaginer que ces salles est de
venir le quotidien de ce que ce qui en
europe et aux états unis
quelques mois plus tard on part sur
londres de nouveau avec arnaud de la
grange
arnaud on se souvient et vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure que boris johnson et ses
conseillers scientifiques avaient dans
un premier temps pariez sur l'immunité
collective
quelle stratégie va être adoptée en
définitive pour contrer le
virus et la pandémie sur place alors
est-ce que arnaud de la grange vous
pouvez réactiver votre micro car on ne
vous entend pas est ce que vous pouvez
me parler ardo on vous entendez pas si
vous avez raison je suis désolé que
voilà donc on entendu la voix de
l'angleterre très bien donc je disais
que des mesures de confinement
classiques ont été prises mais à
l'anglais c'est à dire qu'il n'y avait
pas évidemment de mesures contraignantes
comme ces autorisations à remplir le
masque n'a jamais été rendu obligatoire
dans les rues voilà
mais alors il ya eu alors par contre les
écoles ont été fermées à certains
moments et elle vient d'être ouverte le
8 mars donc c'était quand même y avait
des contraintes assez forte
en revanche la stratégie gouvernementale
a été critiqué on le sait on a trouvé
que les britanniques n'étaient pas
forcément très bon dans la gestion de
l'épidémie est d'ailleurs le bilan est
le plus lourd d'europe il est de 125
mille morts aujourd'hui mais par contre
les britanniques ont très tôt dès le
printemps des mois d'avril miser sur les
vaccins ils ont créé une task force
vaccin six actes qui étaient créés d'une
petite équipe en fait de gens
spécialiste de la logistique de
l'industrie des gens venant du privé
plutôt se dégageant des contraintes de
l'administration qui très tôt a planché
sur les vaccins s'est débrouillé pour
attirer la recherche prévoir des
campagnes d'essai clinique pourra pour
attirer les fabricants de vaccins et on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui ces voix là
c'est la stratégie du tout vaccin qui a
choisi bruce johnson on en est à 24
millions de personnes vaccinées ce qui
est quand même énorme et est donc si
vous voulez c'est dans l'homme dans
l'opinion publique anglaise
il s'est inscrit cette idée que le
gouvernement n'avait pas été très bon
dans tout la première phase où les
premières phases mais parcours s'était
rattrapé par la suite avec cette
stratégie vaccinale encore une fois
assez bien pensé et qui s'est déroulée
de manière de logistique de manière
assez impressionnante lévy je me tourne
vers vous de nouveau comment va réagir
l'italie pour faire face à cette
pandémie qui est massive sur le
territoire italien
quelle stratégie va être adopté mais
tout d'abord avec
ce confinement inédit pour l'histoire
italienne et européenne qui ensuite va
être repris dans d'autres pays
confinement total moi j'avais ma maman
qui a été pendant près de deux mois
enfermée chez elle pour sortir juste
pour aller faire ses courses et avec ces
images qu'on a tous vu de rome et dans
d'autres grandes capitales européennes
complètement vide et ensuite
voilà une pré ouverture progressive et
là nouveau un confinement qui revient la
différence la grande différence par
rapport à la france c'est à dire une des
mesures qui n'a jamais été prise et scié
en revanche en italie a été prise par
tous ses étés dans le déplacement entre
régions c'est à dire que et entre
provinces ou si c'est à dire que les
italiens n'avaient n'ont pas eu droit
pendant très longtemps y compris
maintenant de se déplacer cela si on
habite à rome on peut pas aller à
florence sur comme si on habitait à
paris on peut parler religion ou à lille
voilà et ça c'est une mesure que la
france n'a jamais pris et sinon plus ou
moins confinement classique disons mais
inédit pour tout le monde alors que vont
faire les américains face à cette
pandémie quelle mesure vont-ils prendre
et bien on écoute à ce propos adrien
jaulmes notre correspondant à washington
que nous avons interrogé il ya quelques
heures maintenant les mesures sanitaires
sont du ressort essentiellement des
maires des grandes villes et des
gouverneurs des états il ya 50 et à 50
gouverneurs les grandes agglomérations
qui sont eux qui sont particulièrement
touchés notamment sur les côtes je pense
à la ville de new york ou à san
francisco en californie
les maires ou les gouverneurs prenne des
mesures pour ça dans certains cas des
mesures de confinement
parmi les mesures que prend donald trump
il ya quand même des mesures fédérales
qui sont prises c'est d'investir très
tôt et massivement dans la recherche de
la recherche de vaccins et donc il ya
des fonds considérables on parle
d'environ 10 milliards de dollars qui
sont débloqués et qui sont donnés à des
à plusieurs entreprises de
pharmaceutique qui se lance dans des
recherches sur les vaccins
les etats unis ont recommandé au niveau
fédéral le port du masque
ensuite les états et les villes
certaines n'ont imposé certaines non
certains états l'ont rendue obligatoire
beaucoup d'états sont en train de lever
je pense au texas qui
récemment a élevé la demande de portes
du masque là aussi ça a été très vite
politisé c'est à dire que les les
partisans de donald trump affiché leur
refus de porter de masque comme si
c'était une
c'était une mesure vexatoire voire même
de voir même totalitaire alors que
beaucoup d'autres parties de la
population ont porté le basque est là
aussi il faut se rappeler que les états
unis sont un grand pays géographiquement
très vaste et que les responsabilités
individuelles est souvent considérée
comme étant comme étant plus importante
que les que les directives
gouvernementales dont il ya eu beaucoup
de villes américaines me que ce soit
obligatoire ou pas où les gens portaient
le masque sont ils soient obligés de le
faire
vincent bordeaux n'a vous êtes
journaliste au service sciences et
médecine du figaro il y à louis sur les
réseaux sociaux qui nous demandent
'est-ce que des traitements sont
efficaces
aujourd'hui il a par le vaccin pour
éviter de faire une forme grave une fois
qu'on est déclaré positif pour le mans
c'est le vrai problème de sa maladie
c'est bon on n'a pas trouvé de
traitement il ya eu plusieurs
plusieurs pistes qui ont été lancées
mais qui à chaque fois ont pas donné
quelque chose de convaincant alors il
reste cependant une piste de recherche
assez prometteuse qui est celle des
interférons qui a été évoqué par le
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
pour expliquer très rapidement c'est un
mécanisme d'une immunité précoce qui
arrive très rapidement le virus rentrer
rentrer dans l'organisme et il se trouve
que une partie des formes graves est
liée à un déficit de ces interféron et
plusieurs essais sont en cours des
essais cliniques pour pour valider des
traitements on espère avoir des
résultats dans les prochaines semaines
d'essai des essais en double aveugle
randomisée donc c'est à dire qu'on a une
corps de patients qui suit un
entraînement une cohorte de patients qui
a un placebo et on espère que d'ici
quelques semaines on aura des éléments
rassurants et prometteur à la dessus
encore une fois c'est pas un
entraînement très large qu'il s'agit
seulement des formes graves et une
partie défenderesse que ça veut dire que
concernant lé hydroxy chloroquine qui a
beaucoup fait parler avec ce débat entre
didier raoult et et d'autres
scientifiques
est ce que ce débat est clos est ce que
maintenant les dropkick l'euro qui n'est
plus considéré définitivement comme un
une solution pour traiter les patients
scientifiquement le débat sur l'île
d'hokkaido croquis il a été clos très
très rapidement alors après a survécu
sous ce traitement parce que il ya un
besoin de recourir à quelque chose et
qu'on était quand même des armées
aujourd'hui les vaccins sont là
aujourd'hui on voit que lille roxy clan
qui n'a pas fait ses preuves et donc
petit à petit le traitement disparaît
mais mais des traitements comme celui là
qu'on comprend ce miracle et qui peuvent
nous guérir réapparaissent assez
régulièrement un peu partout sur la
planète mais pour le moment aucun
d'entre eux s'est montré efficace ou non
mais où aujourd'hui dans le monde pour
certains pays la crise relève quasiment
du passé on va le voir pour d'autres le
scénario se répète et des mesures de
confinement sont sont prises à nouveau
sébastien falletti vous êtes en direct
depuis l'asie la crise semble là bas en
chine en tout cas appartenir au passé
désormais on dit que l'épidémie est
éradiqué même si la vaccination est un
peu lente et que la chine est en plein
rebond économique
pouvez vous nous faire un rapide
panorama de la situation aujourd'hui un
an après est ce que vous pouvez
réactiver votre micro sébastien
sébastien on vous entend pas il faudrait
activer votre micro alors je vous écoute
la chine après avoir été paralysé au
printemps dernier s'est rapidement
remise en état de marche à partir de du
3ème trimestre 2009 1 et ensuite la
croissance des revenus et en 2009
finalement la chine est devenue la seule
économie majeure du monde agricole
récession et l'économie maintenant est
reparti au quotidien les chars retrouve
la vie sans masque
mais bien sûr sous 35 immédiate un
risque s'il y avait un risque de 2,2 de
rechute dans 20 ans mais il ya une
difficulté ce genre de la chine qui est
de passer à l'étape suivante la
vaccination a commencé mais elle est
très lente car contrairement à ce qu'on
voit en europe il n'ya pas de santé en
dehors de la chine a érigé une barrière
de garder à l'extérieur tout fait toute
personne pourrait rentrer en jeu des
moyens pourrir on a retenu à l'extérieur
toutes les arrivées de virus pour
garantir une sorte de bulle à l'abri des
virus extérieur et donc pour le moment
aussi l'affectation des saluts comme un
jour mais pour le moment on a simplement
à peine 3% à population qui a été
baptisé et même qu'ils vont aller on
part à londres maintenant retrouver
arnaud de la grange
comment se porte aujourd'hui le royaume
uni face à la pandémie
quel est son évolution justement de
cette épidémie est ce que la stratégie
vaccinale mise en place fonctionne est
ce que ça sorte vaccinale va être mis en
place et puis l'économie du pays qui a
été peut-être impact
elle en est où aujourd'hui ça va
beaucoup mieux alors que c'est quand
même allé très très mal au tournant de
l'année on se souvient que le variant
anglais qui est apparu juste avant noël
et les chiffres entre au mois de janvier
et en février ont été absolument
catastrophique on arrivait à des bilans
de 2800 morts par jour aujourd'hui la
campagne de vaccination encore une fois
au pas de charge 24 millions de
personnes vaccinées
donc en général évidemment les personnes
à risque un porte ses fruits
d'ailleurs le royaume uni pense avoir
vacciné toutes les personnes de plus de
50 ans mi avril et tous les adultes fin
juillet donc ça va assez vite
donc ça porte ses fruits hier on était
noyés à 5000 cas de contamination et
puis 64 morts nommé chief sont vraiment
descendu il ya une stratégie de
confinement qui a commencé il ya huit
jours et qui doit toutes les cinq
semaines ya des nouvelles étapes et on
doit arriver au 21 juin à une
réouverture totale de l'économie
normalement et il l'a reprise aussi
l'aider des voyages internationaux
alors après l'économie évidemment été
terriblement impactés il ya une chute du
pib de 2 à peu près de 10% sur l'année
dernière et le gouvernement britannique
continue ses mesures de soutien
notamment des mesures de chômage partiel
un peu semblables à celles qui ont été
mises en place en france mais qui sont
pas tellement dans la tradition
britannique on sait que les deux
anglaises en tout cas d'intervention de
l'état normalement illimité et bien là
il ya un instant un effort considérable
de fait vous savez ils prennent en
charge 80% du salaire
voilà et ça ça a été vient d'être
annoncé que c'était prolongé jusqu'à la
fin septembre
ça limite ça ça concerne peu près 11
millions de personnes sa limite et
l'explosion du chômage qui est qui est
montée quand même qui est passée de 3,9
pour cent à 5,1 oui je sais c'est des
chiffres qui font fait rêver en france
mais et voilà il ya cet effort
considérable le gouvernement a dépensé
enfin fait pas vous abrutir de chiffres
mais 280 milliards de livres déjà pour
soutenir l'économie et le ministre des
finances a dit la semaine dernière que
le économie britannique pourrait
retrouver ses niveaux d'avant la
pandémie alami 2022 est aujourd'hui le
patron la banque d'angleterre grâce au
succès de la campagne vaccinale dicks
là pour être à la fin de l'année fin
2021 que ça pourrait être plus tôt voilà
où on en est à peu près aujourd'hui
alors quelle est la situation aux états
unis un an après on a joint ya quelques
heures le correspondant à washington du
figaro adrien jour son écoute les
américains comptent à dans ce milieu du
mois de mars 29 millions de cas de
l'infection au corona virus sachant que
le nombre de tests étant évidemment
limitées ce chiffre est probablement
largement plus élevé le nombre de décès
a dépassé les 500 milles puisqu'on est à
peu près à 530 2000 décès ce qui place
les états unis n'ont pas en tête par le
nombre de décès par habitant mais parmi
les pays développés parmi les pays qui
ont payé un lourd tribut à la pandémie
on estime que 75 plus de 65 millions d
américains ont reçu au moins une dose de
vaccin salaires 20% de la population les
etats-unis comptent une population de
330 millions d'habitants et on estime à
35 millions c'est à dire un peu plus de
10% le nombre d'américains qui sont
complètement vaccinés
paolo levi un an après le début de la
crise sanitaire on en est ou en italie
on a entendu et vous l'avez dit
vous-même que depuis hier lundi un
confinement a été de nouveau mis en
place qu'est ce qui se passe en ce
moment et quelles sont les perspectives
de retour à la normale pour l'italie
dans dans les prochains mois écouter
aujourd'hui l'italie à à dépasser la
barre des 100000 morts c'est c'est une
hécatombe
la campagne de vaccination
malheureusement est encore très lente 3
5% de la population seulement a été
vaccinée avec les deux doses aujourd'hui
il ya urgence que l' agence européenne
du médicament puisse redonner son feu
vert au vaccin
astrazeneca qui représente quand même la
part de lion dans dans la campagne de
vaccination et italiennes en grande
bretagne on l'a vu il ya eu 35 cas de
thrombose sur 9 millions de vaccinés
astrazeneca donc c'est absolument
marginal il
lien c'est un petit peu comme si on
interdisait la bicyclette parce que il
ya eu quelques accidents de vélo c'est
complètement ubuesque que cette séquence
cela permettra de rassurer aussi les
gens qui exactement donc il ya urgence
que l'ema donne son feu vert espérant
jeudi pour qu' on puisse reprendre de
plus belle la campagne de vaccination
parce que c'est un élément fondamental
pour la reprise aussi de nos économies
il faut aussi souligner un aspect très
positif de cette guerre sanitaire qu'on
est en train de vivre c'est qu'elle a
donné lieu à un plan de relance européen
qui est absolument inédit c'est une
révolution copernicienne c'est
l'instauration d'une forme de fraternité
enfin entre les pays d'europe et donc il
faut à tout prix que la campagne de
vaccination puisse aller rapidement peut
rapidement pour qu'on puisse enfin vivre
à nouveau une grande reprise et de
nouvelles trente glorieuses non
seulement française mais européenne j'en
suis persuadé mais il faut vraiment se
brouiller avec les vaccins parce que
sinon on va pas s'en sortir dans un bar
de naves vous êtes je le rappelle un
journaliste au service sciences et
médecine du figaro on à maylis qui pose
une question que beaucoup se posent
beaucoup se sont posés et beaucoup se
posent encore peut-on faire confiance à
des vaccins développés aussi vite alors
qu'il faut plus de temps en temps normal
je peux répondre et a maintenant dix ans
on peut faire confiance à ces vaccins
ont vu qu énormément de personnes ont
déjà été vaccinées à travers le monde et
est pour le moment la campagne se passe
se place plutôt très bien et on les
vaccins montre une efficacité redoutable
contre contre ce virus ça a été prouvé
en israël mais aussi au royaume uni avec
plusieurs études très largement menés
sur sur des cohortes assez nombreuses
après la question de la confiance et des
au delà d'efficacité du virus
d'efficacité contre le virus ces vaccins
ils ont qu'à une histoire assez longue
depuis plus d'une dizaine d'années à la
fois les vaccins par arn qui sont ceux
défendus par pfizer et moderna mais
aussi le virus un vecteur viral
comme c'est le cas pour astrazeneca ont
les chercheurs ont si il arrive aussi
vite c'est parce que les chercheurs
étaient prêts il ya une épidémie de sart
sco 20 il ya une dizaine d'années qui a
permis de faire des premiers tests le
virus s'est arrêté de circuler deux par
deux par lui-même
mais la recherche la recherche avait
quand même avancé on n'est pas parti de
rire dit également en masse sur la
recherche les pays qui ont investi dans
la recherche pour des vaccins ont trouvé
des vaccins c'est le cas des états unis
c'est le cas du royaume uni c'est le cas
de la chine c'est le cas de la russie
est bien entendu que la recherche en
amont a permis d'arriver d'arriver à ces
vaccins les pays qui n'ont pas fait le
choix d'investir suffisamment en amont
pour se prémunir et pour trouver ces
vaccins seront soit un peu en difficulté
c'est le cas de la france
alors je ne sais pas si on a le temps de
faire un juste un dernier tour et un
dernier panorama sur les perspectives
d'amélioration et de retour à la normale
pour ce qui est de la chine avec
sébastien falletti sébastien jimdo oui
je vous entends en chine
comme je vous le disais la campagne de
vaccination a commencé mais
contrairement à ce qu'on voit en europe
et asie ce n'est pas une priorité aussi
urgente car la chine est à l'abri de sa
grande murale de la quarantaine et en
chine le virus circule très peu il n'y a
pas eu de cas détectés depuis plusieurs
semaines donc il y a une volonté il n'y
a - d'urgence à être vaccinés et le gore
maintenant veut monter en puissance dans
la dans l'année qui vient et espère
peut-être vacciner environ 70% de la
population d'ici l'automne
mais néanmoins on sent que les autorités
chinoises il n'y a pas la même urgence a
avancé de ce côté là et les autorités
chinoises s'il souligne bien que pour ré
ouvrir les frontières notamment
il va falloir que la fameuse immunité
collective soit atteinte
à l'échelle mondiale donc pour les
chinois il ne suffit pas simplement que
la population chinoise soient vaccinés
mais il faut que le reste du monde soit
aussi que l'épidémie soit sous contrôle
ailleurs dans le monde et donc les
experts chinois m plus tôt ils disent un
horizon jusque de 2 3 ans pour revenir à
une situation véritablement normal et
donc sans doute aussi un abaissement des
contrôles aux frontières qui sont très
strictes toujours un pour venir à pékin
aujourd'hui ces trois semaines de
quarantaine enfermé dans un centre puis
chez soi et de multiples tests et
peut-être bientôt aussi une exigence
d'un vaccin tout à l'heure sur la chine
d'un possible rebond économique qui est
en train d'avoir lieu aussi de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique par rapport à nous
une autre grande puissance en
l'occurrence les états unis l'épidémie
est en recul
odom déjà et le pays donne déjà des
signaux de reprise économique et jayden
redonne en tout cas espoir il a redonné
espoir aux américains il ya quelques
jours en parlant de cette date
symbolique d'un retour à la normale qui
est celle du 4 juillet la fête de
l'indépendance américaine
adrien jour nous en dire quelques mots
les américains espèrent que le que
douceur reviendra à la normale ou du
moins que le les petits délits sera
considérée comme comme juguler dès le
début du mois de juillet joe biden la
semaine dernière a annoncé dans son
discours que l'objectif de son
gouvernement serait de vacciner toute la
population pour le 4 juillet qu'est la
fête nationale américaine
et il a même fixé la date du 1er mai
pour que tous les américains aient reçu
au moins une dose de vaccin l'économie
américaine qui donne déjà des signes de
reprise
on s'attend à ce que la reprise
économique soit extrêmement rapide et
extrêmement importante dès que la
population sera vaccinée c'est-à-dire
dans l'est dans les mois qui viennent
donc les etats-unis qui ont qui sont un
pays avec beaucoup de capacité de
réaction et de rebonds ou un grand
espoir pour la fin de l'année 2021 pour
avoir non seulement un retour à la
normale mais une croissance supérieure à
ce qu'elle a été au cours de l'année
écoulée et voilà ont conclu cette
émission avec les derniers mots d'adrien
jaulmes correspondant du figaro à
washington notre émission touche à sa
fin merci à tous de nous avoir suivis en
direct merci aussi pour votre
participation et vos questions merci
enfin à nos correspondants étrangers on
est désolé on n'a pas pu avoir
thierry oberlé qui était en direct de
jérusalem pour nous parler d'israël et
sa situation de deux champions de la
vaccination et merci encore à nos
intervenants en plateau paolo levi et
vincent bordenave
dans quelques minutes la maintenant on
laisse place à yves thréard et le toc
avec un invité aujourd'hui qui s'appelle
david lisnard qui est en fait le maire
ait l'air de cannes
à bientôt sur figaro live
[Musique]